to solve simultaneously to find points
of intersection my two functions of
course a sine x and cos x so I'm gonna
say it's fine points of intersection I'm
gonna solve sine x equals cos x okay now
at this point you're like hmm definitely
have not done these for a while how am I
going to find the points of intersection
here well you've got two trig functions
and the the easiest thing to make this
the thing to do to make this easiest to
solve is to turn to trig functions into
one what's the way I can combine sine
and cosine think about the identities
that you know to turn these two trig
functions into one maybe your brain is
ticking along and you've recognized what
I can do to both sides is I can divide
through by cos x okay now when I do that
on the left hand side sine divided by
cos by definition is tan and on the
right hand side I just get 1 now don't
forget what I'm trying to do is I'm
solving this in a particular domain so
it's from naught to 2pi so in order to
solve this you've got two alternatives
number one you can think back to your
exact values if you know them well
enough or if you're kind of in a hurry
and you can't remember those you can use
your calculator to help you out your
calculator will only tell you one of the
solutions but from that we can work out
the other one remembering that I'm
expecting two I'm expecting this guy
over here and I'm also expecting this
guy over here all right so what's going
to happen well I know from my from my
knowledge and my familiarity with the
exact values but what I'm looking for
here is PI on 4 you might remember that
better as 45 degrees 10 to 45 degrees is
one you can get that from this triangle
which you might recall this is the one
one root two triangle so it's right
angled and it's isosceles meaning you've
got PI on 4 PI and four in the corners
so tan of course is opposite on adjacent
so if you were looking at either point
of view and the opposite on adjacent
will give you one if you're like ok I
was in a hurry and I didn't remember how
to do that right reach for your
calculator and what you want to do
making sure that you are
radians is if you go shift ten of one
it's going to hand you back a
weird-looking decimal but you know
that's going to be in terms of PI so if
you multiply by 4 you get 3.141592 etc
so you're a PI there so if you wanted if
that was a bit difficult for you you
could put it in degrees right and if I
shift that over right now let's do this
if I go that shift tan inverse of 1 it
will give me 45 this time right so maybe
that's a better way for you because you
don't have to try and get rid of the
PI's so pi and 4 there's the first
solution but I know I needed another now
what's handy is I can't see that pylon
for does match in fact my freehand
sketch was good enough that you can see
PI on 4 is smack-bang halfway between 0
and PI on 2 so thumbs up for that graph
where is this other one where am I going
to find it now my tip for you here is
that you'll need to remember that 10x
which is what we're dealing with down
here right tan X like or every other
trigonometric function is periodic it
repeats every now you have to think
about how often he repeats sine and
cosine repeat every 2 pi that's why on
my graph I've got one full cycle of each
but tan X repeats more frequently than
that its period is only pi 1 pi I should
say so if I have a solution at PI on 4
and then I also have a solution PI
radians later which is 5 PI on 4 you
know it's worth mentioning that's not
the only way to get these two solutions
if you wanted you could have gone for
the all stations to central alternative
and we worked out that the first
solution pine for is this in the a
quadrant in the first quadrant and then
the second quadrant will be down here in
the third quadrant which is 5.4 because
I've got 10 X being positive which is in
your first quadrant and your third
quadrant so either of those ways to get
your solutions is fine all right so now
I've got a PI on four over there in the
top left-hand corner and then my five PI
over four is over here and if you think
about it five point four is one in a
quarter lots of Pi which shouldn't
surprise us because there's pi
right there so five pound four should
say x equals five point four will just
be a little bit past pi okay take a
breath I've just spent some time to work
out these points of intersection why did
I do that it's so that I can evaluate
the area so I can work out my lower and
upper bounds if you have a look
carefully I do have three areas here
right I've got I'm just gonna call them
a1 like I have been will call this guy a
2 and then you've got a 3 over on the
left on the right hand side excuse me I
should say so a 1 a 2 a 3 let's deal
with each one in turn now what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to duplicate this graph
just so we can have it close to where
we're doing out working down below over
here and I'll just make it a bit smaller
because we don't need it to be enormous
I want to be able to see it though so I
can work out from where I'm going to
stand and each integral okay so I'm
gonna work out a1 is going to be think
about it carefully I'm gonna start from
naught and then I'm gonna go to that
first point of intersection which I
found at PI on 4 for this part of the
graph it's gonna be green takeaway blue
which is cause takeaway signs so he
comes the integral cos x minus sine x
and that's what the track 2x is a1 a2
the next one over I takes over at PI on
4 it goes all the way to the second
point of intersection which we said was
5 PI on 4 and this time I'm doing blue
takeaway green so this is sine X take
away cos x with respect to X the last
one is a3 which takes over at 5 PI on 4
and then it ends at the very end of the
domain which in the question was defined
as 2 pi and then we return like a 1/2
cause being on the top and sign being on
the bottom okay now at this point I'm
gonna pause because I could naturally
just start integrating and then start
evaluating and I will get the answer
I'll show you that a bit later on
but as in
cases if we do a bit of thinking here we
can actually help ourselves out and make
this question especially the evaluation
of all of these integrals I'm a lot
easier for ourselves here's the way you
need to think about this you've got all
of this symmetry within these
trigonometric functions a lot of things
are equal to each other and maybe you
recognize that already for instance if
you have a look over here at a1 I'm just
going to take this section over oh don't
get rid of this for a second just so
it's not in the way I'm going to take
this section over here of a1 just gonna
copy that because I wonder if you've
noticed yep copy
I wonder if noticed that it actually
fits on to another part of the graph if
I just paste this as an image over here
you can see on the right-hand side of
the graph and we should have predicted
this because sine and cosine are course
periodic functions this a1 fits exactly
on to the end of a 3 if you know domain
had continued past 2 pi and this is what
the rest of the areas would look like
now when you look at this combined a3
plus a1 the pink area now I'm just going
to get rid of this one on the left hand
side since some kind of whoops that's
too big I'm just considering over there
on the right hand side so let's just get
rid of this one since I've sort of moved
it over okay what have I got here what a
to the yellow area and a1 plus a3 which
is the pink area they look suspiciously
alike in fact they're not suspiciously
alike they are exactly equal to each
other but there's a horizontal
reflection that's happened there
so in fact I can say that a2 is exactly
equal to a1 plus a3 so in order to work
out the total area which is a1 plus a2
plus a3
what I can really do is I can just say
well just work out one of those areas
either the left-hand side it's all the
right-hand side and then just double it
once you've done that you've got all
three combined together let me just say
that one more time if I want a 1 plus a
2
plus a three then what I can say is
because it's the total area if a2 is
equal to let's highlight it a one and A
three we had them in pink then I'm just
going to substitute a 1 and a 3 for
another a 2 that will give me my total
area and clearly that's going to be an
easier thing to evaluate than all three
altogether and I'd rather prefer to
evaluate one integral rather than two
integrals and because it's just less
work for me to do